hello everyone
when students are about to start a phd
they are faced with a number of
important and confusing questions
questions surrounding the issues of
selecting and giving precedence to the
research supervisor or the institute or
the research topic
now these questions can take on a
multitude of forms and in an earlier
video i had addressed the important
question of whether one should go with a
new young faculty as one's research
supervisor or a senior more established
professor
and in this video i am going to address
the very important question of whether
one should give precedence to the
research topic or the research
supervisor now if you do not have the
time or the patience to go through the
entire video
the quick answer is that
always always go with the research
supervisor give precedence to the
research supervisor over the research
topic
but
if you want a more nuanced answer with
proper justification listen on so if you
think that you have a favorite research
topic
what is the basis of that thought why do
you think that you have this favorite
research topic is it perhaps because
that you did your bachelor's project or
your master's project in that topic
because if so do understand that
your bachelor's project or your master's
project is more of a gateway for you to
understand the research methodology how
to do the literature survey how to write
up a report how to carry out simulations
and experiments how to interact with
others in the research group so these
are some of the basic things the
mechanics of research which you are
supposed to be getting familiar with as
part of your bachelor's and master's
projects so that is much more important
those things are much more important
than the actual research topic
furthermore
do also note that what is what was it
that prompted you to take up this
masters project or a bachelor's project
okay
why why did you start working on that
topic what were you perhaps guided by
your own interest in that topic or
perhaps it just so happened that due to
some administrative decision in the
department you got randomly allocated to
a professor because he happened to be
free or perhaps it was just
on the basis of your roll number
because if that is the case
then
just think for a moment will you let
that random
chance
dictate the rest of your research life
now let us say for argument's sake that
there was no such accidental random
allocation for your master's project and
that you did approach a professor out of
your own interest and you actually did
the work
on a particular topic out of your own
interest and it is based on that kind of
a background that you want to do your
phd on that very same topic
and now perhaps you are thinking that
you have already invested at least a
year or perhaps even more
as part of your master's project
on that topic and you do not want
to
let that experience that time investment
investment of energy go to waste
but
very important to note here is that
compared to masters project
a phd is a much much bigger compar
commitment in fact there is no
comparison
okay it's a much bigger commitment it's
a much longer commitment and then when i
say longer i do not just mean long in
the sense that a phd journey is of a
duration of four or five years
i mean it in the sense that when you do
a phd with a particular supervisor it is
a lifelong relationship okay it's a
lifelong journey actually
so
having a great supervisor is of utmost
necessity
in fact as i had already mentioned
earlier it is much much more important
than your actual research topic because
even in your phd
your supervisor may be teaching you a
few things especially initially
on the particular research topic but
much more importantly than that he would
be teaching you some of the actual
uh ropes of the trade
what i mean by that is he would be
teaching you how to actually do research
and that teaching is absolutely
irrespective of the kind of
topic that you are working on
he would also be teaching how to
actually write papers
how to
how to find an appropriate research
question so these are the kind of skills
which are completely independent of the
research topic
so if you have a great supervisor who
can actually mentor and guide you in
these very very fundamental skills
okay very ground level skills
which are absolutely necessary
in any kind of research in any topic
that you may be doing in the future
then that will be a real real value
addition much more than this the spoon
feeding kind of uh
of guidance that you may be expecting
and in fact that is not going to happen
also furthermore note that especially in
india
your relationship with the supervisor is
going to uh
as i already mentioned it is going to
span out your entire life so
in many kinds of
for many kinds of recommendations you
always have to come back to your phd
supervisor absolutely essentially
okay so it is especially important that
you can work with such a supervisor with
whom you can develop a good healthy
relationship
uh that will benefit you
in your entire life because to
understand that
if you do stay in academia then in all
likelihood you would not actually be
working in the exact same topic that you
would be working in your phd later on
you would be deviating from that you
would be opening up new research areas
as as an independent uh
academician
and then your research supervisor will
have nothing to say on on those topics
okay so
but despite that
his recommendation uh his connections
will matter to you
okay so my personal advice is that
always always give precedence to the
research supervisor try if you get an
opportunity to work with a great
supervisor even if it means that you
have to sacrifice so to speak sacrifice
your your research interest from your
master's project days do so start
working on the new area and logically
just think you have invested just one or
two years of time at most during your
master's project on that research topic
now when you start working on your phd
the topic which seems new now when you
are about to start your phd after just
one or two years it will no longer be
new in fact i guarantee you this that
after one or two years
the amount of knowledge and experience
that will have in this so called new
topic will be much more than the top
than the knowledge and experience that
you have uh on your masters
project research topic okay so this is
something that you must must um
understand another important point is
that when you are starting your you know
when you're about to start your phd you
should be open to the possibility of
uh
of trying out or or starting your work
in a new and exciting research area
okay because it may have so happened
that in the place that where you did
your master's project uh maybe that area
was
uh was not an active area of research it
maybe no professor was there who was
working on that
and perhaps if they were there you'd
have ended up working uh in that area
itself so now that you are getting a
chance to work on such a new and
exciting area why not go for it
it will stand you in good state in the
future
uh now you may think that
okay
you are perhaps open to this uh idea of
working in a new area but what will the
professor probably think about it that
you do not have any prior experience
believe me on this
if your fundamentals are strong
okay if your fundamentals are strong
then
most professors
will be very happy to take you as their
phd student
irrespective of the fact whether you
have prior experience on that
it's a certainly a bonus if you have
that prior experience but it will not be
a tremendously negative thing uh so you
don't have to worry on that account
okay and please note that suppose
suppose you have some experience like
you are you are going to work in an area
uh
which in which you have already worked
during your master's even then your
supervisor will be
somewhat circumspect about
the in-depth knowledge that you would be
having
okay so he will anyway have to train you
once you start your phd on those on that
topic properly again
okay
one final point to note here is that
suppose you are you have become really
really interested uh in your master's
topic
okay
so
my question to you is
why don't you consider actually
continuing with that professor
okay why go to a different institute why
go to a different professor now you may
be thinking that okay you want to go to
some big university big place
but i think it's a it's it's a wrong
notion
okay
if
you are actually enjoying working in a
particular area probably more than the
area what you're actually enjoying is
actually
enjoying with your master's project
supervisor
so try to think very honestly about this
point
so if you have a nice communication with
your master's project supervisor and
there is a possibility that
that you may continue to work with him
for your phd i suggest strongly suggest
that you considered doing so and this is
particularly true if you see that there
is some kind of a possibility of a
publication from your master's work
okay because that will give you a head
start uh in the absolutely essential
requirement of having proper
publications in your phd so if you go
into your ph recall into your phd
program with the with that with the uh
with that inertia with that momentum of
actually uh
going for a publication right from the
very start based on the work that you
have been doing with the same supervisor
in your master's then nothing like it
okay so with these very general tips i
will conclude the video and i wish you
all the very best in taking the correct
decision which is unique to you all the
very best